e
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ans
suffit il à l'endroit même où vous
m'avez tous prédit je me tuerais ce
n'était pas une prédiction c'est un
mauvais sort que vous n'avez jeter tout
s'est passé exactement comme vous l'avez
voulu vous avez provoqué la lettre qu'il
a écrite et puis à la date que vous avez
désigné le 1er avril nous nous sommes
vus et il ne m'a parlé que tous en forme
sa femme toujours sa forme
alors j'ai crié j'ai crié mais puisque
ta femme sera toujours entre nous
puisque tu ne la quittera jamais c'est
moi qui te dit partir m'attendre je veux
plus voir
il est sorti du parti lui il m'a quitté
le mans il a sauté sur l'occasion
je ne pourrai jamais supporté qu'il
méprise homos c'est tous les hommes sont
allés chaque fois qu'on leur dit de
partir il n'y aurait plus de couple et
d'amour oprean moi il n'ya plus d'amour
je reconnais ce n'est pas un homme qui a
dit non ce n'est pas un homme qui
revient et vous savez bien vous il ne
faut pas qu'il revienne
pourtant vous savez je suis pas c'est
qu'un jeu sans même en moins calme
effrayant le calme des grands moments de
l'existence celui des destins accepter
ça fait encore dans ma tête comme un
bruit doux sur les rochers mais mais je
sens déjà en moi quelque chose de froid
c'est terriblement france et la mort
avec des pêcheurs vous mon enfant je
l'aurais vu elle n'y est pas j'aurais
aimé mourir ni sur un sable fin cet
endroit encore adieu au bordel vous
aurez peut-être cette mort là si vous
l'avez rêvé nous agissions sur la mort
aux rats sont si vous êtes un coeur pur
et c'est la fierté des coeurs qui
commande à tout moment l'anémié vers
celle ci commence à tourner à la mairie
je fume je suis pur et c'est ce qu'elle
n'a pas compris
il avait fait de moi son instrument de
plaisir je l'étais plus de sens pour lui
alors que dans ses proches celui donné
mandat n'en revenais pas
plus j'y reviens cg me revient pas en
vivre que jeune puisque rien n'existait
pour moi qu'en fonction de lui
vous voyez bien qu'il n'y a pas d'issue
que le monde est fermé je vous le dis
mon enfant la mort n'est pas sûr comment
pouvez vous dire qu'elle n'est pas sur
moi puisque je les ai dans ma poche et
que je n'ai qu'un geste à faire pour
maurice mois sont en hausse tout à fait
pas son geste le faire ici non qu'on
appelait les freins
[Applaudissements]
le bien les sensations super pour le nom
qu'on a choisi soit mais qui sait je
n'ai pas raisonner mais c'est vous qui
l'avez dit c'est vous qui l'avait chassé
c'est pas lisse vous abandonnez la seule
chose qui compte pour nous c'est de
savoir sur l'a6 où celle ci s'en va
cette fois c'est vous non mon petit nos
on ne suit pas le jour on commence à
peine à respirer aller respirer vient
allonger vous la donner ma chérie tu as
réussi les risques et libéral genevois
qui vous revient allongez-vous jamais
les yeux et santé maman sur votre front
c'est maintenant que la vie commence
pour vous depuis des années vous
étouffer sa jeunesse là dessus mais vous
aider à sortir vous avez dit le vertige
et vous avez voulu mourir parce vous a
semblé que vous n'appartenez plus au
monde des vivants
la nuit a été longue très longue ils
étaient mariés cet imbécile
oui c'est nous
vous voulez passer sa femme quand tu
nous marier petit n'a pas touché sa
femme au bout de trois mois pour la
nouvelle venue ce qu'il ne quittera
jamais ce que s'est installée dans une
vie qui fait de son affaire à ce [ __ ]
en amour m'apprécier tous les maris sont
des [ __ ] il faut comprendre de sa
bourgeoisie kg a mis longtemps à
comprendre mais maintenant ça y est
quand tu sors du casino qui a fédéré
5032 qu'elle se soit abstenue jamais
quand ils organisent tu viens de gagner
quelque chose de plus grand cent mille
francs tu as gagné fortune
tu as gagné le droit de respirer
justement respire
tu te dis que tu es seulement ça ce
n'est plus la face à tous les autres qui
ne trahit pas facile et cela j'aime
l'amour passe à l'amour l'amour ce n'est
pas toujours été d'être seul avec tous
les autres tu verras que l'amour pour
tout le monde est bien plus grande que
celui qu'on peut donner un pauvre
misérable imbéciles qui ne mérite jamais
le véritable amour petit le véritable
amour et d'une force tellement
formidable qu'il n'y a pas une êtres
humains qui se passe et tout s'est
écrasé c'est pour ça qu'il n'a jamais
que de malheurs dans l'amour des hommes
et des femmes
il a toujours un qui se creusent et
c'est pour ça il ya aussi deux voyants
comme vous pour ramasser les morceaux et
pour leur coller quelques fois et filles
[Musique]
bien très bien mais le temps si tu vas
me dire que je l'emportais que cette
collection va dormir pendant une bonne
heure ce sont mes plus profonds que le
sommeil normal quand il se réveille dans
la foulée donnera ou d'elvis qui incarna
comme ont tous remercié ont compéti
qu'est ce que tu veux de notre métier
n'est ce pas depuis quarante ans que
j'exerce jamais une histoire pareille du
match est arrivée elle est entré ici
comme une folle en disant qu'elle allait
se suit devant moi moi je ne savais plus
comment la calmer mais karma mais c'est
encore plus extraordinaire que je ne
pense pas non plus entrer ici tu me
parler comme si tu savais tout d'alcool
si certaines de ses clients mais vous
avec lui
et si vite mais je n'ai rien lu j'ai
entendu simplement où ça ou sable
derrière la poste ou une voyante ce
n'est pas très honnête d'écouté derrière
la porte mais c'était encore le moyen le
plus sûr de ne pas se tromper
valeant levitte qui a vu le résultat
avec 3 et terrell l'a plus dit amo
notamment des convois qu'il commandait
de vives je lui dis géniaux city n'est
pas la mouche au style te connaissent et
moi j'étais là bas du destin joue verte
c'est pas comme si je tombé du ciel
tombe du ciel karma cet intérêt
d'ailleurs là si cette étude sera là
aussi allongé avec le même visage de
cire les yeux fermés dire que le plus
grand mystère du monde est là dans un
corps immobile le coeur bat à une
batterie la vie la mort je sais je sais
que pour toi c'est la même chose la vie
la mort et que s'il était morte à 5
minutes qui était déjà à la recherche de
son esprit mais ma conversation avec lui
pour maintenant
jacques wattez juin et rendormi je pense
à ce que l'invisible kibaki basse
batterie mike brusquement roi rené
plupart
non je ne pense pas que c'est la même
chose je pense que c'est tout à fait le
contraire
aa et qu'il faut être fort mais fort
comme tu dit croire que les morts les
morts arrivent quand les appellations
téléphone ou sur internet chacun de nous
a sa spécialité
je ne crois pas du tout dans ta
spécialité moi je proviens latine et je
crois que dans ta spécialité tu ne
dépasse tout
tout pourrait me faire l'honneur de le
temps franche et directe d'une
championne je m'amuse à me mettre en
colère et qui a raison ce sont les
autres qui sont fous qu'elle jouerait
les autres qui ne connaît pas mais je ne
te fais pas dit c'est que ça le moment
est bien choisi
avec ce qui se passe maintenant au tour
du match du concarneau il faut battre le
fer tant qu'il est chaud
est-ce que puis à noter le rendez vous
samedi à 8h30 chez moi et c'est chat
histoire ce qui est toujours je pars
demain matin
concarneau je serai de retour samedi
pour la réunion
ah oui très bien nous sont nombreux à la
réunion i do i chez moi ne seront jamais
le comité au complet il ne faut tout le
monde
ah oui il ya aussi chez rihanna ya bien
longtemps que je n'ai pas toujours aussi
fun ne changera plus maintenant la
pauvre pour qui sait qu'elle a imposé un
compte dans la profession c'est un fait
rare et puis très gentil j'invite aussi
la secrétaire après la faille et là où
il ne comprend rien à rien mais il ne
comprend rien avec passion et pour ce
que j'avais une faut de la passion
j'espère que tu seras que tu as cette
fois ci que ce sera du côté des vivants
de quoi s'agira d'une réunion
eh bien mon petit c'est pour le savoir
que je te demande d'être là parce que je
te dirai des choses que j'ai vues avec
l'hommage de concarneau est une chose
très sérieux enfin voila tu as eu tort
de lui annoncer sa rupture pour une date
précise de cette malheureuse
on a tu sais moi j'avais lu 1er avril
qui sait que moi les dames c'est aussi
la spécialité
c'est en tout cas spécial éthique qui
peut qui provoquent des catastrophes
la date était mal choisie comme poisson
d'avril il préférait autre chose qu'on
veut plus tu sais bien qu'on ne choisit
pas vous avez le 1er avril en tueur
étudie le commencement d'avril c'est la
même chose que si tu te trompe toujours
dit que tu ne connais rien si tu tombes
juste honteux très de sorcières on te
dit un responsable de ce qui arrive
je vous ai toujours dit par des dates
par d'état si tu m'avais écouté le 16
décembre tu n'aurais pas eu un accident
est très bien 16 et sommellerie madame
et où le 15 à 11 heures du soir m'a
appelé au téléphone pour me dire que le
lendemain je sers renversé par une auto
place de l'opéra le lendemain ça fait le
siège sa venue la tête justement ces
biens culturels tenir compte
je ne vais rien faire place de l'opéra
jamais dit qu'il n'y a pas de danger
alors ce jour là avenue kléber attaque
site a renversé une femme mûre cas c est
à lui de moins de vitesse c'est ce que
je te reproche
tu donnes trop de détails si tu m'avais
pas parler de l'opéra je serais resté
tranquille chez moi mais tu m'as dit
qu'une auto va me renverser place de
l'opéra je n'y vais pas être tranquille
là dessus ton auto vient me chercher à
minutes les verts
dans les bois de trouver d'emploi il
connaît mieux voir et que les rester
chez toi et je te crois encore une fois
je n'ai pas été place de l'opéra oui
mais alors tu comprends la voiture qui
ne tient pas trouvé place de l'opéra
comme convenu et à l'écart au marché
allemand et ce par quoi je t'avais dit
que ce jour là tu seras murs et place de
l'opéra mais le ch décembre - la paix
c'est assez mais c'est le drame de la
voyance toi la nuit les pieds dans des
pantoufles derrière sa table de travail
qui m'a vu inversé par une auto et moi
lendemain en plein jour c'est toto je
les ai pas vus il évalue que nous soyons
pas vaillant qui est nul autre que je
tourne les yeux de bons côtés
toutefois quand tu me verras l'inversé
ne me tue pas dans quelle rue ça va se
passer je vais réussir un cliché moi je
t'embrasse à samedi les cela laisse
encore dormir un peu quand on se reverra
plus dira qu'il a beaucoup parlé en
tournoi et que la vie plusieurs fois va
donc qu'elle était heureuse
les gens croient toujours que si parle
en dormant ils disent la vérité
quoique le grand pas c'est ce qu'ils
appellent leur vérité que je ne crois
pas tu vas nous a tout à leurs 20 ans
ici tu étais sûr que je savais tout une
malheureuse même que je l'avais lu d'une
façon quelconque d'une autre mais
simplement compris que j'étais derrière
la porte à mai et autres ce malheur qui
comprend toute la vérité et qui
expliquent toujours tout avec les
raisons de sa raison c'est tout ce que
je n'ai pas envie s'il m'avait demandé
pourquoi je suis arrivé ici dans ce
moment dramatique
probablement parce que tu passais dans
le quartier des invalides du tout
j'étais dans un taxi place de l'étoile
je rentre tranquillement chez moi et
tout d'un coup on voit mahdi rouge en
vallée au secours de foix rose avant
appelé au secours
alors je suis arrivé voilà à carmat de
nous toute la pollution
car notre extraordinaire à raison
extraordinaire je suis une voyante qui
entend chacun sa spécialité
[Musique]
je
quand mademoiselle je suis sûr que je ne
me serais pas on décide ou fait entrer
avant que madame carnaval à madame kaba
vous aime beaucoup et elle s'intéresse à
vous je le sais vous me fait plaisir
moi aussi je l'aimais beaucoup c'est une
femme si extraordinaire n'est ce pas
quelle nature généreuse
quelle intelligence d esprit et baker
quel don et là on ne se trompe jamais
vous savez au nom quand tu étais pas sûr
de quelque chose ou quelqu'un ne dit
rien mais quand elle est sûre quand elle
a entendu tous les saveurs du monde
toutes les sommités de la science la
remise donc de ce qu'on voudra
voudraient s'opposer à elle n'en
demandent encore je vous envie beaucoup
de vivre constamment auprès d'une femme
comme elle ou il ne savait pas quel
bonheur vous avez promet si je le sais
et je ne perd pas une occasion de le lui
dire est lent merci ça fait 12 ans voyez
vous que je suis sa secrétaire
enfin son assistante mais surtout son
ami et sa confidente et bien je n'ai
qu'un désir dans la vie c'est comme adam
karma vif très très longtemps et que ce
puisse la seconde est il à servir
jusqu'à son dernier jour où le ciel
parce qu'ils soient loin heureusement je
crois qu'elle n'a pas l'air menace est
connue
si vous saviez que l'activité la pensée
qu'elle travaille de 15 à 16 heures par
jour 16la par jour mais le matin à 8
heures elle est instable et elle écrit
correspondants et qu'elle correspondance
on lui écrit du monde entier articles
interviews arbitral communications
société d'occultisme à elle est aussi
président des voyantes de france ce qui
est une charge qu'on ne soupçonne pas eh
bien ça matinée passe comme ça ces
travaux il ya ces lettres à midi et nuit
elle déjeune et à une heure et demie
elle commence ses consultations alors
moi le soir je pense qu'elle va se
reposer se relaxer guinée ah non pas du
tout elle me demande un livre reçu la
veille ou le matin même et l on commence
la lecture en grignotant une poire une
grappe de raisin c'est tout ce qu'elle
mange après 11
de consultation jamais plus de deux mois
parce que moi j'ai toujours pas elle
m'appelle biscotte parce que je suis
tout le temps en temps dans grignoter
juste c'est devenu mon nom moi je crois
que si elle m'appelait parlons véritable
nom sauraient pas qui elle parle elle va
être bientôt prête elle est revenue il
ya un moment d'un voyage en province oui
madame
je suis ici via deux pilotes des
biscottes bhutto merci madame non faut
pas marc mercier ce n'est pas un cadeau
c'est un souvenir de première nécessité
pour toi bonjour manche et si nos jours
nada j'étais ici avec mademoiselle qui
vous attendait alors je l'avais fait
après vous avez fait bon voyage
quel est mon voyage assez connu je peux
vous vraiment sans vous déranger je
n'avais pas pris de rendez vous que
c'est toi c'est toi qui as des commandes
et les autres m'ont pas tous madame
hélas pas tous crins qu'entre 7 et 8 ce
que je veux garder seulement de ceux qui
en a déjà trois qui attendent depuis
longtemps lui renverra les autres tu
devras que je suis en voyage des sens
voilà oui ça comment vous permettez je
vous en prie et les charmantes
mademoiselle vie c'est la chaire mal
mais je ne sais pas comment diable fait
de manger tout le temps dans douze ans à
laval et une tonne
alors mon petit comment vont les choses
il ya de nouveau je vois pourquoi voix
de marc que tu es venu me voir ça pour
fuir de nouveau il se dessine
je vous ai apporté sa dernière m ce
pacte vise les vraiment avec les yeux
fermés je dois là dedans vous vous me
dites ce qu'il n'écrit pas révélé ça te
fait ça fait sophie cette lettre je
crois qu'il n'est pas du tout de suite
il fallait vous nous entendez quelque
chose vous croyez que sinon ce n'est pas
fini du tounoi son père son père qui se
met en travers qu'est ce qu'il a dans la
tête c'est lui l'acte en attendant le
petit et faible et son père a fait de
projets pour son avenir alors y résister
résister mais ne résistera pas que l'on
nous vous écouter il m'a dit qu'il va
proposer de déposer situe attendent un
enfant
il l'a même jugé ah oui oui bon mais
alors pourquoi tu me dis pas tout de
suite que tu es enceinte mois gourmand
moi je ne sais pas mais non c'est pas
pour ça que tu es venu me voir
franchement tu attends un enfant mon
petit se passerait tout à l'heure
brusquement il est entendu que je
t'avais dit qu'il a quelque chose de
nouveau c'est ça le nouveau mais vous
êtes sûr je me suis jamais trompé devant
femme enceinte du mois et demi comme toi
rebelles à ce merveilleux c'est inespéré
tu veux dire il vous voyez s'il tient sa
parole aussi mais j'entends des cloches
ce n'est pas de cloche d'enterrement
donc cela marie avec lui à la fin de
mois de juin
merci madame karama est ce que vous
accepteriez d'être la marraine la
marraine de ton enfant
je veux te dire pourquoi parce qu'il
sera le fioles du sorcier pourquoi il
sera très content de le dire quand tu
seras petit mais ça lui fera du tort
quand il sera grand
comment pouvez vous dire ça ledit petit
parce que je ne sais tu vois je reçois
ici de lettres du monde entier
je reçois chez moi des hommes d'affaires
des ministres des deux prêtres des
artistes je rêvais que sa mitre bien sûr
mais auprès de dire à qui sort de chez
moi il raconte d'alléger la sorcière
je ne vais pas qu'un jour de l'enfant et
de sa marraine la socié
si j'avais eu un enfant mon petit je me
suis arrangée de telle façon que
personne ne sera jamais que j'étais sa
mère madame karnas vous êtes bien sûr
que j'attends un enfant comme moi je
suis sûr que je n'attends pas sa musique
ne me trompe pas mon petit vous entendez
des musiques différentes selon qu'il est
temps et bien oui j'entends de bruit de
son de notre quelquefois et pendant
quarante ans j'ai appris à quoi il
correspond tout ce qui existe animé opa
émet des ondes le bon dieu m'a fait de
telle façon que je le reçois c'est une
fois sa cible comme tu vois je n'ai pas
de secret s'il ya un secret tribune du
mafé comme je suis pourquoi c'est son
affaire vient me voir chaque fois que tu
voudras âge de prendre de clients
merci merci pour tout il y avait ce côté
jeux la farofa oui tout de suite avant
mada
mademoiselle disparu et n'est pas du
corps va leur faire autrefois madame
montant les biscottes rang et de tessons
bonne solution
alors le courrier presser pour nos
portes ou enfin parce à 1h prête à vous
avez reçu un coffret de terre du
guatemala la paire de boîtes mal à
supporter bonheur mais non c'est le
ministre de l'agriculture qui vous
demande si vous pouvez lui dire à
l'avancé si les récoltes sont bonnes
cette année les réponses de quoi de 12
suppose mais je ne savais pas que
notamment la ministre il faut jouer que
le président du conseil pour le prévenir
oui ce sera pour exemple est bien aussi
à monsieur vente quelque chose là qui
vous écris de hollande pour vous
demander si vous pouvez faire l'
expertise d'un même ligne et reconnaître
un sou par le 12 bref entre douze
apôtres il faut que je reconnais judas
est un peu il s'enfuit gens qu statu quo
alors que nous jouons devinette
nous avons déjà les médecins continuent
si nous mettons aussi expertisé de
tableau mais qui s'adresse aux lyrics
c'est leur affaire ils ne seront pas
traités de fesmy un pont vers cet
instant un moment tout à fait un trait
qui est sûr c'est une dame qui n'est
jamais venue bon
[Musique]
madame vous venez de la part de qui de
la part de personnes madame je vous
connais comme tout le monde de
réputation et je me suis décidé
quand on vient chez moi pour la première
fois on se décide toujours c'est un peu
comme une femme honnête et se décide à
l'adultère c'est une grave décision
excusez moi madame si j'ai dit ah vous
qui vous a froissé un du tout madame du
tout du tout du tout que pourrais je
faire pour vous madame vous avez perdu
votre mari à 18 mois
oui 18 mois exactement ici bêtement mais
oui justement subitement une attaque en
sortant de table au madame vous êtes
extraordinaire mais comment c'est vous
que vous le dit madame je ne fais que
répéter il en escroc histoire de papiers
d'affaires
c'est pour ça que je suis venu oui oui
il ya un escroc vous l'avez vu vous le
voyez mais c'est miraculeux je ne vois
rien j'attends simplement qu'il est un
escroc raconter mon mari peu de temps
avant sa mort avait fait une mauvaise
affaire
ils avaient dû emprunter de l'argent et
notamment une somme importante à un
homme dont il ne voulait pas rester le
débiteur aussi on nous vend du une
propriété qui m'appartenaient pour que
mon mari puisse rembourser ses dettes
en fait tout au moins celle là et je
sais qu'il l'a fait il me l'aide
mon mari n'avait pas de secret pour moi
notre vie avait été très heureuse et je
peux dire qu'aucune ombre n'a existé
dans notre ménage à aucun moment
et voilà qu'un peu plus d'un an après la
mort de mon mari cet homme il n'y aurait
plein mais son dû or si mon mari m'a dit
qu'il avait remboursé c'est qu'il l'a
fait l'ayant fait les certain qu'il est
j'ai une décharge qu'il détenait à
papier une quittance une lettre prouvant
qu'il avait remboursé
seulement voilà il est mort d'une
attaque foudroyante en sortant de table
comme vous l'avez dit je cherchais dans
tous ses papiers depuis cette
réclamation je n'ai trouvé nulle part ni
à son bureau ni chez nous la quittance
indispensable pour pouvait le
remboursement
mon avocat m'a dit qu'il n'avait aucun
moyen de me défendre si je ne retrouvais
pas cette pièce là l'espèce exigé par le
créancier
oui oui et justement mon mari me l'avait
dit ce qui prouve bien qu'il avait
remboursé ne mourrai pas donné ce détail
s'il rend dans ce monde n'avait pas été
fait je vous répète madame que mon mari
et moi avons toujours vécu dans la plus
absolue confiance
est-ce que vous avez lettres sur vos
deux classes hier
oui oui j'ai pensé qu'il me demanderiez
ça j'en ai une
heureusement est un objet appartenant à
votre mari
j'ai apporté son alliance donnez moi la
vôtre aussi
vous avez une maison à un étage villa au
pavillon de près de l'eau et oui à saint
cloud en effet au 1er étage à côté de
votre chambre
il a un pièce qui a servi de vivre à
votre mari oui c'est ça à gauche entre
la fenêtre mur il un secrétaire comment
vous le voyez aussi mais je cherchais
dans tous les papiers dans tous les
tiroirs je n'ai rien trouvé
la quittant cela madame dans le
secrétaire devant nulle part ailleurs et
je peux je veux même pas vous dire
comment elles sont faites les autres
meubles gens voient que le secrétaire et
j'entends il à quelqu'un je vois ce
moment oui oui ma fille doit être rentré
passé au bureau matin le téléphone à
berthod et appeler votre fille
[Musique]
allô allô c'est pas chérie
oui oui c'est moi à temps non je ne
quitte pas un instant des puces se
trouve la clé du secrétaire à l'eau
écoute je vais te demander de faire
simplement ce que je te dirai non non
non ne pose pas de questions je
t'expliquerai en rentrant oui oui mais
c'est très important
voilà ouvre le deuxième tiroir de la
commode dans ma chambre à droite sous
les chemises de nuit
il ya une boîte plat dans la boîte il ya
une clé en cuivre qui a bien compris
elle en a pour une minute le très jolie
bouille le blog oui avec des grands yeux
bleus
oui c'est ça à l'eau à l'aube tina bon
ne dites pas que je vous le secrétaire
va ouvrir le secrétaire du bureau de
gaza
on nous prend pour un téléphone à
victoire est belle c'est le troisième
tiroirs de loi attend attend qu'il tire
tout à fait tuer la banque ouvre le
secrétaire et tient complètement le
troisième tiroirs de droite il n'y a pas
en plein il résiste qu'elle tue un peu
plus fort tire un peu plus fort ça y est
ça y est
le maintenant
qu'y a t'il madame à ton équipe pas un
instant yat-il madame je ne sentais pas
bien d'ouvrir j'appelle vie à votre
schéma dans ces regards sur fond de
secrétaire à gauche il un plat plan sur
le bois sans toucher à rien alors écoute
regarde sans toucher à rien surtout si
au fond à gauche il n'y a pas une plaque
blanche dans le voit mais enfin sur le
bois regarde et le vincent oui madame
allô oui oui il ya la plaque qu'elle me
le tueur à la place qu elle vous attend
surtout sans toucher à rien
mais pourquoi madame en mettant à l'eau
le réfléchir et ne touche à rien surtout
remet le pouvoir en place y attends moi
non non non je serai là pour le dîner
mais oui attends moi tranquillement et
expliquera quant à tout de suite
qu'y a t'il madame natus certaine que la
pitance soit là mais difficile il
poserait cas de conscience terrible je
vous avez changé de visage tout à coup
tranquilliser noah jeu du bonheur pour
vous madame et du malheur mais je ne
peux pas vous donner les indications de
l'autre sinon je l'aurais fait carrément
mais malheureusement je ne peux plus je
le suis encore quelque chose et qu'il
vînt fera sur ce bout de papier on met 3
par exemple je puis l'idée de rien à
voir n'importe quelle phrase madame
terme à trouver le double fond de ce
caractère assez bien
alors oui oui oui oui
en rentrant chez vous madame vous allez
à très très fort sur la plaque blanche
en rendez vous en tirant très fort vous
allez découvrir le double fond de
secrétaire la quittance et là vous en
êtes certains oui madame ouïe la
quittance est là mais vous allez trouver
aussi des lettres madame beaucoup de
lettres dont l'écriture est ronde et
penché à droite
l'avr mais juste le contraire
quant à madame vous voulez dire alors
j'ai permis de découvrir une escroc je
vous sors d'une catastrophe financière
les vous m'avez dit qu'aucune aucune
ombre à traverser votre ménage pardonnez
moi si je vous fais découvrir en même
temps ce qui va détruire toute révision
de votre vie je n'ai pas voulu que votre
fille phase de découverte à l'âge de 20
ans c'est tout ce que je pouvais faire
des lettres d'une femme madame j'ai été
obligé de découvrir tous ces lettres
pour trouver la quittance ans madame ce
que vous me dites est affreux voilà
je vous demande pardon
madame en rentrant chez vous brûlé brûlé
tous et les trousses en délire croyez
moi ça ne sert à rien et ça va faire un
mois du mal et pardonnez moi
qu'est ce que je pouvais faire qu'est-ce
qui vaut mieux être ruinée par l'escroc
pour apprendre que son mari a aimé tout
ça vient notre faim quel métier
mon dieu quel métier c'est pauvre dame
avait l'air bien bouleverser
elle était sur marne n'a jamais trompé
j'étais obligée du mat obligé de lui
donner la preuve contraire ses terrines
oui c'est terrible ça y est mort lui
arracher le secret de toute sa vie
qu'est ce que tu vas me réserve est la
suivante c'est aussi dans ce jeu suivant
mais il ya les deux fait un trait de
lamberto oui madame madame
bonjour attarde bonjour madame
madame vous allez peut-être trouvé fold
à cause de ma visite
ça m'étonnerait beaucoup oui j'imagine
que l'on vient toujours vous trouvez
avec plus ou moins cette phrase aux
lèvres se bornent merci maintenant je
vous écoute mada et bien voici ce qui
m'amène mada juste sors à l'instant du
cabinet d'un grand chirurgien qui après
un examen ne voit qu'une chance pour moi
dans une opération très sérieuse au sein
gauche 5 gauche le chirurgien n'est
jamais tout naturellement
enfin on peut dans certains cas
comprendre à quoi ils pensent et deviner
leurs convictions c'est une très grand
chirurgien
je ne peux pas vous dire son nom vous me
comprenez
mais sa réputation est très grande la
vôtre les taux si madame et j'ai su que
dans des cas semblables aux miens
précisément votre diagnostic avait été
le bon approchez vous et donnez moi
votre mal
en
5 gauche oui
tout ce que je fais vous dire madame que
j'ai toujours entendu la maladie à
laquelle vous pensez
dans certains cas c'est moi qui ai dû
aux malades dans les bars le chirurgien
non
je m'entends bien
vraiment vous n'y croyez pas je vous ai
pas dit que je crois non j'entends je
n'entends pas et pour vous je n'entends
rien mais si vous aviez un décideur
alors je vous dirai dans les voir le dr
pelletier ce le plus grand et nous avons
toujours le même diagnostic
alors madame je peux le dire c'est lui
qui veulent opérer d'urgence il dont
totalité mais oui c'est lui qui pense
oui
non non non non non on entre enfin en
clinique non mais vis-à-vis de lui que
puis je dire je ne peux pas opposé à son
diagnostic sylvie de voyage à nous
excuser moi madame je ne voulais pas
être malade était venu chez moi pour
quelque chose
oui c'est vrai plus vous pensez que je
veux croire mais mon âme et b vous dira
que vous êtes folle entre le docteur
était l'associé avec harmonisé par
madame c'est une responsabilité qu'il
prendra part moi je l'apprends de madame
pouvez vous vous absentez de paris 48
heures mais sans alerter votre mari oui
c'est très possible c'est possible et
bien la patte et demain matin
concarneau voir le match dont parlent
les journaux on revient madame c'est une
phénomène c'est du médium extraordinaire
et la maladie c'est sa spécialité
s'il vous dit comme le dr pète et
j'accepte le verdict s'il vous dit que
moi
revenez me voir j'ai fait raymond à
faire auprès du docteur je vais vous
donner un cadre à temps pour le match il
s'appelle kadlec voilà messi est bien
juste et demain un concarnois vous tient
au courant je vous prie de la passer me
voir ou téléphonez mois entendu à
bientôt
à bientôt
à cette cuisse est lui que vous avez
dans l'appétit fait plus vous empêchez
d'un teint de ce cui
qu'est-ce que tu enseigner du matériau
passionnant assassin non sens qui sont
ces recherches aux siens
mon dieu mais que ce parce qu'il est là
qu une femme au
vous vous les appelez la police la
police pourquoi la police ne me croiront
pas d'autant plus que sa dette une année
la police n'est pas notre affaire la
police
il attendait depuis 5h30 il avait l'air
tout comme un mouton bandol de votants a
bien pu l'amener ici savoir s'il ira en
prison
la baisse à 5,5 au bout de ce printemps
quand ils sont pas arrêtés mais ils
commencent à s'étonner on commence aussi
à espérer que les chars feront à leur
tour vers nous pour savoir ce que nous
les voyons derrière les barreaux
quelle journée mon petit quel jour
escota c'est toi la vie éco fiscaux de
l'image de concarneau c'est un génie
vraiment je veux dire un phénomène au
phénomène auprès duquel sont peu de
savoura moi comme les autres phénomènes
cet horizon il sait à peine lire et
écrire mais quand il est dans son
sommeil nautique il va même à distance
la maladie de quelqu'un il donc dans un
langage absolument professionnels le
diagnostic le traitement et la main
ensemble dossiers qui prouvent que cet
objet jamais jamais trompé ni dans le
diagnostic et dans le traitement mais
c'est miraculeux ski miraculeux le
médecin a commencé à se mettre contre
lui tu ne fais pas savoir ce que ça
représente pour nous pour nous tout et
surtout parce que j'ai envisagé de faire
vous n'oubliez pas que vous recevez
toute la leur ces dames du comité ont
encore du country que je peux oublier
chose pareille quand il faut les
convaincre
ça s'appelle se sont-elles surnom sont
en avance oh oui
à
quant à fort de rosa et moi et toutes
les deux en avance un bon quart d'heure
ça ne fait rien on on te dérange
m'appelle non au contraire moi quand
j'ai lu les journaux naturellement j'ai
maudit mais comme tu nous avais dit que
tu allais à cancale c'est le ciel qui
vous arrive est plutôt assez vous là je
vais vous en parle je vais vous parler à
battre les autres arrivent avec leur
concarneau mais je vais vous parler est
aussi l'ennemi aujourd'hui d'en savoir
un peu plus ce qu'est ce que c'est que
ça regarde tu as lu ça toi compte ainsi
aux ahmadis allemand l'ordre des
médecins quand l'hommage de concarneau
moment je prends colonnes le contraire
aurait été étonnant
et qu'est-ce qui tissent et surtout qui
fige une moyenne position affichée il ya
vait smith la santé publique
l'expression de leur inquiétude quant à
la tapageuse publicité faite autour de
celui qu'on appelle déjà le mage ainsi
signé médecin je revienne conseil de
l'ordre
et bien lui aussi et qui donc héritier
il fait partie des signataires
c'est ça que vous ne compterez je sais
que tu as un faible pour le mvno qu un
faible pour lui non seulement opéré
après mon accident et ont conduit
toujours tellement de bien tu vas idées
comme les ou comment peut-il nous
abattre les autres fait partie du
conseil de l'ordre ne peux pas être
content de ses confrères voilà ça j'en
sais quelque chose
le professeur damien comme vous le savez
peut-être deux cousins mon mari ma chère
si tu savais ce qui dit de moi dans la
famille pour lui c'est bien ça c'est une
forme une folle qui s'amusent à faire
tourner les tables en les poussant avec
le piller il est même allée jusqu'à
écrire un article dans une revue
médicale pour expliquer que ce ne sont
pas les tables picard mais les lustres
de nogent
non vous vous imaginez comme c'est
vraisemblable les muscles de l'eau gens
qui se mettent à craquer juste au moment
où on fait tourner une table et qui en
dehors de ça ne craquerait j'appelle
voilà quand j'ai des articulations qui
traquent comme tout le monde mais pas
d'un muscle mes muscles n'ont jamais le
moindre bruit
je ne saurai quand même je suis parfois
neeson a commencé avec la bêtise machin
c'est entendu c'est en voulant que ce
n'est pas vous qui claquent et à les
quais sont les craquements mal vais vous
parler plus sérieusement c'est ainsi
qu'il ne peut pas tomber mieux
j'avais grecque le docteur issa dans le
coup mais ce n'est pas ça qui m'a
empêché rencontre et je lui dirai entre
quatre yeux ce que j'en pense
je lui dirais qu'avant de signer cette
facilité il fallait prendre le temps
d'aller à concarneau moi je le fais
alors tu l'as vu travailler dix mois ce
mage et il est beau dans la on m'a dit
qu'il était très beaux prés la commune
je veux lui parler de génie non elle me
demande s'il est bon mais rappelle le
génie et la beauté vont ensemble
c'est à dire qui a raison du bruit le
mot à hilla d'un certaine beauté paysans
paysan breton
on commence par ne commence pas à taper
sur le peloton écoute d'abord souffert
c'est en est le médium hypnotique total
et pour nous c'est une bénédiction
nous allons prendre sa défense je vous
ai prié de venir pour obtenir de vous un
accord pour réunion monstre à la salle
wagram ou à la porte de versailles où
les sorciers lèveront la tête quand le
médecin qui se moque de nous contre le
pouvoir qu'il n'accepte pas et contre
ceux qui rient qui se croient les plus
forts parce que nous claque ce convoi
nous sommes peut-être pas la vérité mais
nous sommes une vérité et cette vérité
autrefois été respectée il faut pas
oublier que nous sommes les filles les
filles de sybille et des pythies elle
faisait figure des divinités et nous
nous sommes par la loi l'oracle de
delphes est notre ancêtre
il avait le droit da au temple d'apollon
et nous vous en plus seul au centre au
sol de quartier de l'europe est bien
long
j'aurai ta vie que les sorcières sortent
de leur tanière que le monde entier nous
reconnaissent et qui nous saluent braves
non ma chérie aux bravo il m'a ému au
lard et brémond péter jeter ne pas voir
des deux mains mais j'aime bien la
formule si tu leur parles comme ça tu
auras tout le cabinet avec toi oui mais
nous devrions maintenant organiser un
grand défilé dans les rues
nous passerions sous l'arc de triomphe
ou alors à valrose dans l'espoir que
radio oui et moi fait rage avec et puis
me direz ça c'est une idée reddition il
a une idée magnifique oui oui ni des
roses a juste le contraire de ce qu'il
faut faire pour pression comment
pourquoi ceci me voyant de lancer en
plein paris nous allons pour 50 ans
n'aurait mec moi ce que je veux je veux
qu'ils nous prennent au sérieux les
voyants sous l'arc de triomphe minutes
ça sera en effet à domine mondial mais
mondiale ah oui tu as raison mais ton
idée géniale c'est de rappeler aux gens
l'oracle de delphes et de leur dire
qu'il est notre en scène va la faire
c'est vrai nous en descendant en ligne
directe
sinon comment expliques-tu qui est pas
auvergnat gels accent grec
ce dernier à faire demi tour je serai
jamais relatée par uche ma mère est
hérissé mon père dernier âgé dé destiné
à rouler les r av j'ai cultivé le christ
les français sont tellement
nationalistes pour un voyage ne peut
être que russe la russie
c'est le droit la folie saab à venir de
raspoutine tout ça
l anrac d'edf c'est encore mieux que la
russie un mois c'est ce que j'ai répondu
dans la famille de mon mari à ce qu'ils
n'approuvaient pas notre mariage
je leur ai dit un jour en plein dîner
notre famille il ya 400 ans que la
mienne quatre amis dans la question a
été réglée une fois pour toutes très
bien le ballon
les organes eh bien nous allons passer
dans la salle à manger nous selon mieux
autour d'une table kwapis dit voyant
autour d'une table le savent attaquer
le aux beaux-arts ça va ça va très bien
mon petit très bien nul ne résiste à
votre choix et à votre courroux but le
téléphone et par les dossiers avec toi
je veux donner un coup d'oeil
je réponds à celui là oui oui répond
seulement cela mais c'était ça mon petit
réfectoire à l'eau oui madame
sa secrétaire de la part de qui je vous
écoute madame oui donc très bien au
revoir madame madame c'est une dame qui
est venu tout à l'heure elle m'a dit
vous dirai à madame carla que les
lettres étaient bien dans le secrétaire
c'est mon petit je sais je sais mais pas
la quittance comment et la sauver tous
les lecteurs
mais pas la quittance mon dieu c'est
gras pauvre femme
mais qu'est ce que j'ai fait
[Musique]
c'est pourquoi nous conseillons aux
mamans peuvent employer jamais pour la
toilette de leurs enfants que le savon
qui mousse qui pousse le savon qui fait
la peau douce avec ti mousse or et
mousse d'après nos informations
politiques et notre page de publicité
voici nos informations générales à la
une de tous les journaux du matin le
projet de loi déposée par un groupe de
parlementaires sur le bureau de
l'assemblée nationale il rendant à
autoriser certains médium guérisseur à
exercer leur art sous contrôle médical
il semblerait que le démo de ce projet
de loi ne soit pas étranger à la séance
d'envergure que les voyants étaient
occultistes ont tenu ces jo dernier à la
salle wagram sous l'impulsion de mal car
ma d'un célèbre extralucide voilà une
première victoire pour les adeptes des
sciences occultes puisqu'il s'agissait
de nous s'en souvient pour l'homme car
mode de faire échec à la science
officielle dans la sphère du mage de
concarneau comment la faculté va-t-elle
réagir
paris se passionne pour ce match bien
particuliers qu'aux dommages
il sent bien que tout à fait indifférent
à l'agitation qu'il provoque
aux dernières nouvelles il serait depuis
plusieurs plongées dans son fameux
sommeil nautique peut-être pourra-t-il
dire avant toulouse comment les choses
se terminent le ps ils ne comprennent
rien à rien les ironies l'uprona ton
supérieur crétins
mais ces temps là enfin mon sommeil
hypnotique
mais ce qu'ils savent seulement quoi il
parle des mitrailleuses voilà ce qu'il
nous faudra et des mitrailleuses son
fameux sommeil hypnotique ports audio et
vous allez oui
ouais oui c'est exact monsieur madame
karma interrompu ses consultations au
sens plus rien vous dire de plus
monsieur sinon que pendant quelques
temps madame karma ne reçoit pas une
huitaine c'est probable l assesseur
téléphoné à ce moment là je suis très
aimable
au revoir monsieur
le coup de téléphone qu'il arrive doit
naturellement ça c'est la radio dire
qu'il va falloir être aimable avec ces
gens aimables mais leur dire ce que je
pense
et ben alors attendez là vous êtes c'est
la transition
bon voilà vous pouvez entrer si vous
êtes pression va tâcher de ne pas être
trop long c'est pas moi que vous venez
interviewé ce pense madame karma c'est
pour vous oya sa photographie en
première page de tous les journaux vous
me demandez si c'est moi j'avais
journaux on n'a pas le temps de
s'endormir deux ans vous savez quand
même ce qui vous êtes qui vous venez
interviewé on m'a dit que j'allais chez
la reine des voyantes à propos de deux
types de concarneau et du projet de loi
déposé à l'assemblée nationale
on m'a remis un peu comme expliquer quoi
il retourne
vous êtes d'ailleurs avec le magnéto n'a
pas besoin de savoir franche où on voit
tout de suite à qui on a affaire alors
aux deux ou trois questions
l'autre et on bascule il le dit c'est
dans la boîte nous on n'a rien à y voir
on apporte sa touche à quel tour est
joué m s'il fallait connaître l'avis de
tous ceux chez qui on va travailler on
en trouvera mieux avec vous au moins on
est fixé et je ne m'étonne plus d'avoir
entendu qu'à cinq minutes le temps de
stupidité à la radio merci quand même
je le dis comme je le pense ce monsieur
qui se permet d'y organiser de faire de
l'esprit au sujet de celui que vous
appelez vous le type de concarneau
permettez moi de vous dire monsieur ça
ne fait pas honneur à la radiodiffusion
goût mais doucement nuance moi je suis
postes privés et bat lui aussi justement
n'est pas monsieur
où allez-vous ouais mais il n'ya presque
privé pasteurisé a chez nous c'est tout
autre chose
là je vois vous verrez alors ici nous
sommes chez la reine des voyantes
c'est marrant mais je me parle peu
rock'n qu'elle perroquet mais je crois
que j'ai les voyantes y avait toujours
un perroquet aux dommages alors bien ça
c'était bon pour le son et pour le
reportage un perroquet internet
avidement des brad est là faire
latéralement puisque vous êtes de la
maison je n'ai pas besoin de vous
demander si vous marchez vaut marcher à
fond
pienaar enfin je veux dire vous y croyez
quoi mais se croient à quoi monsieur zhu
pris aux tables tournantes que le
bastringue on est madame carla ne fait
pas tourner de table si vous voulez le
savoir nous manquait ce qu'elle fait
alors moi je croyais que les vaillants
faisait d'abord quand warner c'est par
vous allez vous encore monsieur vous
accuse même pas visiter l'appartement
voulait venir ici
vous avez encore beaucoup à apprendre
sans vouloir vous faire de peine à bas
je suis là pour ça en marquer nancy est
chouette dans notre métier on arrive
chez quelqu'un on sait rien on en sort
on sait tout tient ce matin je suis allé
mettre en boîte le super directeur de
l'uranium en france un sur quelqu'un et
bien c'est fou ce que cette chose depuis
ce matin sur l'uranium mais cyclotron
les poltrons poule b tran huy vous
connaissez la question avant impôts ils
m'ont a raconté pendant trois quarts
d'heure bien compliquée j'en ai cinq
bobines et bien croyez moi pour remplir
cinq bobines pour connaître son truc
non oui madame jeudi ainsi de suite
baby dont elle est gracieuse comme
informateur ça pue celle là
je ne sais pas ce que la reine n'a
jamais très vite quand elles sont en
tête à tête mais moi qui ne suis pas
voyant je lui prédis qu'elle trouvera
pas seulement un type dans mangeant pour
le groupe d ce classement
le barda nous sommes dans un pub en mars
nous attendions quand je pense qu'il ya
des dingues défilé toute la journée pour
se faire raconter qu'ils vont rencontrer
l'élue de leur coeur bat roddick les
gens soient ils ont su ce que je vais
faire court et je me demande ce que
fabrique nicky houba montjuic ont encore
tremblé qu'au delà je la mettrais une
fausse piste je lui raconte que je suis
pas sûr d'un outil et je lui demande de
me dire ce qu'elle fait en ce moment
dans paris comme elle a pris l'avion
pour nice à une heure où elle est partie
en portage du avoir tel va pas tout
changer la reine
on va se marrer alors voilà alors
maintenant un boulot boulot de la
distinction jusqu'au bout des ongles
je m'excuse je vous ai fait atteint va
rester avec mademoiselle mamsell nous
avons déjà eu le plaisir de voir
mademoiselle et le dark très aimablement
dans d'autres femmes et qu'elle flotte
moi je suis radio libérer mon camarade
en même temps que photographe et
correspondant d'un journal suisse
nous étions chère madame de ne pas vous
déranger trop longtemps et de sciez vous
intéresse et qui par conséquent
intéressant aussi notre viseur vous avez
toute façon c'est la planche de quoi de
ce que nous allons dire ça sert à
quelque chose
non non vous savez tous voulaient me
demandez pas moi oui mais j'en suis sûr
ah non là n'est pas mauvaise en plein
figure pendant tout le temps que je
parle non non non
une ou deux fronts temps d'abord pour
commencer ma vraie quoi il ne vous
ennuie rapport avec cela il prendra des
naudières n'est ce pas en est
5 4 3 2 1 0 nous sommes dans
l'appartement de la célèbre madame karma
celle qu'on appelle volontiers la reine
des voyantes et qui vient de provoquer à
paris les remous que l'on sait madame
karma puis je vous demander pour les
auditeurs de radio univers de dire à
notre micro
quel mobile vous ont poussés dans la
campagne que vous avez provoqué en
faveur de la vaillance et des sciences
occultes
ce sera ma première question
on repart à zéro
et vous le voulez bien oui ils marchent
sur les trucs là oui
surtout alors madame surtout ne vous
inquiétez pas ce coup presse qui sera
inutile en fait il faut pas une première
mais à partir du moment où vous répondre
à mes questions je ne pouvais rien
envoyer trente jours après ce sera ma
première question quelle question
il invite mon vieux question en veux tu
que je te réponds si tu ne dis pas
qu'elles question je l'avais déjà dit
c'était pour ne pas répéter
de toute façon j'aurais raccordé au
montage mais je m'en foutais au montage
c'est en effet ce matin que ce serait
moi je suis cependant rappelé que cathy
tout à l'heure elle laisse assez
ma figure est assez connue en suisse oui
oui oui ça suffit pour les poteaux à m
là nous énervons pas
cinq a320
madame karma puis je vous demandais pour
les auditeurs de radio univers de dire à
notre micro quel mobile vous en pousser
tout particulièrement dans la campagne
que vous avez déclenché ce sera ma
première question c'est pour attirer
l'attention de foule et celle des
pouvoirs publics sur l'existence de
réalité que la science officielle persie
on n'a pas à tenir
vous voulez parler des forces occultes
en général je vais pas mettre tout ce
qui existe qui se comprend pas si on
veut expliquer rationnellement par
exemple par exemple mozart par exemple
l'hommage de concarneau est il par
exemple diminué home et c'est très
intéressant et c'est très inattendu
yehudi menuhin et pourquoi yehudi
menuhin lorsque j'ai assisté à son
premier concert à l'opéra quand il avait
10 ans en fermant les yeux progresser
l'intrigué du violent alors tout le
monde a dit que cet enfant était géniale
tout le monde messieurs étaient
enchantés d'avoir trouvé ça mais
pourquoi cet enfant était génial et
comment expliquer ces génies sa mesure
personne n'a réussi à le savoir le
moment à la pensée logique monaco résolu
le problème
moi je crois qui m'a rien résolu du tout
et que la question reste posée
c'est d'ailleurs tout à fait juste merci
beaucoup un enseignant au lieu de jouer
du violon avait fait des prédictions on
n'aurait pas dit qu'il était génial
également des fumistes richesse à
l'exploiter mais le violon on ne peut
pas faire autrement que de l'entente
alors on s'incline tandis que devant le
match de concarneau ne s'incline pas on
ne dit pas c'est peut-être aussi
extraordinaire que mes nuits
on dit ça n'existe pas j'ai réglé avec
monsieur j'ai été le voir et entendre je
vais crier au monde entier que ça existe
qui n'a pas là dedans les finistériens
charles addams mais vous avez remporté
une victoire éclatante puisqu'un projet
de loi a été déposée avant-hier sur le
bureau de l'assemblée nationale
c'est un buteur mais ce cas le projet
cela passait et selek comment réagir à
votre avis la faculté n'avez qu'à
demander à d'autres pays mais pas à moi
à vous connaissez cette opé levier c'est
très très grand chirurgien
il m'a opéré après mon accident mais il
a fait partie de ceux qui au début de
cette affaire ont signé une mise en
garde contre le match de concarneau je
crois oui et vous n'avez pas été tenté
tu si vous le connaissez de le voir
personnellement et de lui parler du
match de concarneau s'était allumée cdh
a mal été tentés de venir me voir belle
n'a pas fait et malefosse était publique
à la salle wagram et on peut dire
retentissant merci beaucoup
vous même madame karma vous êtes une
voyante très célèbre non non non je
préfère ne pas parler de moi pourtant
votre expérience personnelle est très
importante
avez vous souvent vu chez vos clients
des maladies qu'ils ne soupçonnaient pas
je n'ai fait que ça depuis qu'alain vous
êtes vous sûr on tromper mais mon départ
pour suivante le médecin
l'enterrement quand vous vous êtes
trompés l'avez-vous toujours su qu'un
médecin ne dit jamais que ce trophée
mais un médium a redit tout de suite
tout ce que je vais vous dire monsieur
qui la demande a dit sur lequel je me
suis jamais jamais être et à quoi
attribuez vous votre faculté
extraordinaire tout ce qu'on a fait
l'extraordinaire il faut l'attribuer à
l'esprit c'est à dire adieu et c'est la
suisse d'être extraordinaire puisque
l'esprit petto parce que vous croyez en
dieu jettera l'expliqué le principe est
le moteur si vous avez vieux principes
et l'esprit
je prends dieu et que pensez vous de
ceux qui n'y croient pas à l'esprit où
est dieu qui n'est toujours fait lui de
penser à l'échelon le plus bas c'est à
dire c'est lui de la matière oui parce
que vous ne croyez pas en la matière
mais c'est la matière ce n'est pas je
crois à la victoire de l'esprit sur la
matière et c'est pour cette victoire et
j'ai ma part mais ne pensez-vous pas
madame que l'homme à l'époque où il
marche sur la lune a tout de même d'une
certaine façon vaincu la matière je
crois monsieur qui l'a vaincu la
résistance de l'air et perfectionner la
résistance de matérieux c'est tout
écrite il a été sur la lune neil a
trouvé que la lune dans mon analyse non
le mystère n'est pas dans la lune
monsieur il est dans la clairvoyance
extraordinaire de l'homme endormi à
concarneau six mois je m'en vais sur le
monde blanc et ben je dirais que c'est
autre chose qu'ici que la lumière est
clair que les ruptures
c'est tout ça m'avance à rien je vais
plus loin
quand je lis un livre beige dans le
coeur de quelqu'un qui est en face de
moi et en plus je n'ai pas arrêté semble
raid des sables du monde blanc
cette rallonge donc pour vous l'avenir
de l'homme n'est pas dans la science
actuelle mais dans celle des forces
invisibles parler de l'avenir de l'homme
et celle fuites sur canal et encore un
on peut se demander justement si la
science appuyé le précisément les
laissera son avenir
maintenant c'est mode qui vous pose la
question on va ça alors chapeau avec ça
c'est une chute formidable oui mais vous
avez le sens de l'interview madame et de
la phrase choc
ernest ans étaient deux premières tours
et bien non je suis enchanté d'être le
premier bourgeoisie comme je ne pense
c'était passionnant et première ensemble
vous êtes réconcilier avec les voyantes
à ça c'est une autre question
quelques semaines quand tout à l'heure
monsieur avait l'air plutôt sceptique en
c'est dommage je suis c'est dommage
parce que je voulais vous proposer
d'aller demain matin l'hôpital de sico
var le docteur pitié ouais pourquoi
faire bah parce que si vous ne vous
soyez pas mon bon ami vous aurez nous
sert à l'estomac
g
jalousie j'avais vu que j'avais mal à
l'estomac alors ça c'est fort alors
parce que c'est vrai c'est tous cas plus
vrai ces magouilleurs surtout à 2 heures
du matin 28 le dr pelletier ont valeur
mais mais comment avez vous vu que
j'avais mal à l'estomac or il ya des
mois que j'ai des brûlures et plaies et
vous dites que je vais avoir un ulcère
je dis qu'il faut dr pelletier ça
d'accord madame tout de suite alors
docteur petit hôpital boucicaut dans
votre bain de la vôtre mais puisque je
sais que j'ai des brûlures à l'estomac
et que vous me dites comme ça au premier
coup d'oeil je suis bien obligé d'y
croire mais j'y crois j'y crois et je
dirais même que je vais vous faire une
drôle de publicis ici parce que ça c'est
formidable pour notre mot reste et je ne
sais pas mais moi on peut dire que vous
m'avez promet alors madame karma je vais
me permettre de vous poser une question
personnelle votre petite amie quoi
vous l'avez vu aussi que je voulais vous
demander quelque chose sur ma petite
amie n'a rien fait du tout je voulais
simplement me reposer la question parce
que ça arrive que des hommes viennent
vous demander si leurs petites amies les
troncs ça arrive souvent et vous le leur
dit jamais pourquoi à ce que c'est
toujours vrai c'est toujours vrai
qu'elle les a trompés savez monsieur qui
ont commencé à se poser la question
il ya longtemps que j'ai déjà fait
et bonne voyez maintenant en fait
qu'elle les a trompés vous le savez
d'une façon seulement actuellement il
que je leur dis jamais c'est une
décision que je prends pas pour tous
remarqué moi je voulais vous demander ça
pour rire non c'était vraiment pas parce
que j'étais inquiet ça vaut mieux aller
pourquoi je dis que ça vaut mieux de ne
pas être inquiet vous dites ça expo mort
d'une façon générale un nom j'ai dit que
ça vaut toujours bon ben alors ne
parlons plus injuste que je n'ai aucune
raison d'être inquiet non dans la
question que je voulais vous poser celle
ci puisque vous voyez ce que les autres
ne voient pas et on avance dans certains
cas pourquoi les voyantes ne gagne pas
le tiercé à chaque coup et pourquoi ne
vous installez vous pas monté carl
devant la table de la roulette envoyant
chaque fois le numéro qui va sortir
ah voilà la question que je pose
voyez-vous et que beaucoup de gens se
posent aussi c'est simple mais c'est
parce que le gagnant du terrain de la
lutte il n'a pas son voyage c'est très
simple en effet mais pourquoi justement
et pourquoi justement quand je suis
rentré dans cette pièce je suis que vous
avez un ulcère à l'estomac
c'est parce que quelque chose à mam
relatif est pourquoi je ne sais pas de
numéros gagnants de thierry c'est parce
que alors c'est quand même bizarre oui
c'est bizarre que je sais pas le numéro
gagnant de dire si ce n'est pas bizarre
que je sais que vous avez l'outil
réalistement ça ce n'est pas grave
oui oui en effet il a toujours raison si
vous voulez mon avis que si nous avons
avant son numéro gagnant le tiercé ça
sera immoral et l'esprit ne jamais
immoral l'esprit ne souffle pas aux
guichets du pmu il faut vous y faire
je suis et n'oubliez pas demain matin
l'hôpital psy cobourne de perpétuer au
cymbalum d'accord alors à 9h30 sur le
vent m'a pas sur le frein de mon pays
vous avez le sto ma maladie se méfier
pour tout le monde
qu'est ce qu'ils veulent ils m'ont dit
que l'émission aurait lieu après demain
à 18h et cooper avec toute la craie du
noir je me demandais où il voulait
arriver avec le docteur pays si oui je
l'attends de pied ferme mais tu vois la
bombe le docteur prestige mag
entièrement au il ne doit pas être
content le docteur sa vie le projet de
loi sur le bureau de l'assemblée doit
être curieux oui sérieux ne me suis
jamais autant amusé que tout à l'heure
les en boarder où il avait retourné
comme un gant à bien entendu alors
qu'ils prenaient mère du monsieur fini
crois pas une croix rien studio là mais
rien de plus qu'un bulletin croyant
physiquement oui
l'autre était muet il m'a dit au revoir
aux partants
lisez aussi parce que moi elle émue et
je les entends comme personne
d'autres ma petite vie madame est ce que
tu fais vraiment attention téléphone
depuis quelques jours au madame mais
comme toujours pourquoi la dame que j'ai
envie à concarneau et n'a toujours pas
téléphoner un autre jour pas mal c'est
important très important j'attends des
réponses très important pourquoi
par contre la dame qui cherchent un kit
anges
vous avez de la trouver oui le trou
profond de s'égrener lundi un
portefeuille oublié dans une poche de
veston
je suis très contente pour cette pauvre
femme pour moi
je me suis trompé
je devais vous le dire quand même bien
sûr
beaucoup de gens téléphonent pour savoir
quand vous allez reprendre vos
consultations qu est ce que je dois leur
répondre que tu ne sais rien parce que
je ne sais rien ma mère envoie je crois
que vous allez vous ennuyer très vite si
vous ne les prenez pas maintenant que la
réunion de la salle wagram a eu lieu est
beaucoup plus libre de ce côté là ce
n'est pas ça qui compte mon petit ce qui
compte c'est le coeur le coeur beaucoup
n'avaient jamais eu le coeur malade deux
stars le coeur à l'ouvragé le ketchup
cette conférence je crois que c'est en
dernier vous avez assez prouvé que vous
l'aviez pas vraiment je me suis forcée
parce que je me suis trop avancé que je
ne pouvais plus reculer
mais le soir quand cette femme a
téléphoné que la trouve ces lettres et
par la quittance ce soir là quand il a
fallu que je rejoins les autres pour les
convaincre que ce soit à la télé c'est
pas les femmes qui m'a fallu que je
passe époque j'étais comme champion qui
jouait sa carrière et qui a prouvé ce
tir que la femme qu'il aime le tron je
viens d'apprendre que je me suis trompé
jamais jamais je me suis trompé pour une
chose aussi grave je travaille aux morts
je lui arracher le secret de toute sa
vie
et cette pauvre femme qu'est-ce qu'il
doit souffrir avec tous ces lettres ne
nous nous avons le droit d exercer
sûrement si nous sommes des été
bénéfique sinon les autres ils ont
raison nous sommes des sorcières qui va
ma petite
dans toute ma carrière je crois que je
donnais du bien aux autres à foix
parfois c'est vrai je donnais des
illusions mais dans l'illusion il ya
l'espoir d'aller marquer quand il sort
d'ici comme ils sont plus vifs plus
solide qu'à leur arrivée lui toujours
pas toujours risque toujours pas ce que
je veux redonner quelque chose à croire
viens je voyage en chine par exemple tu
peux pas savoir l'effet du voyage en
chine tu ne peux pas savoir combien
d'argent ils ont vécu avec l'espoir de
faire ce voyage arrive et quand parfois
morin ils ont compris qu'ils ne feront
jamais ce voyage et ce sont peut-être
des carmes à se tromper mais par un
parent à penser karma m'a fait vivre
pendant des années avec l'espoir de
faire ce voyage ils n'ont jamais douté
est ce cela qui est agréable savoir
donner de révo autres
attention moi non plus il ne faut pas
que j'aie doute ça peut être le docteur
où il est en avance
non
non non il ne faut pas que je doute non
c'est une jeune femme à qui j'ai dit que
vous ne recevez pas mais elle insiste
pour vous voir elle dit que vous vous
souviendrez certainement d'elle vous
l'avez vu il ya quelques temps si madame
rose elle vient pas se tuer chez moi ou
vous cinéma c'est là je trouve ça petit
si gentil et bien détruit seulement cinq
minutes
oui mais attention quand le docteur sera
là dans le petit salon mais rappelle toi
rappelle-toi quand il ya du monde je ne
vais pas mon dieu je veux pas qu'on va
le docteur ici mais soyez tranquilles
madame je l'affirmé
oui bonjour mademoiselle joly bonjour
madame vous vous souvenez de moi bien
sûr je sais que vous avez peu de temps
accordé mais je n'ai pas pu oublier tout
ce que vous m'avez dit chez madame rosa
quand vous n'avez calme et endormie avec
tant de douceur
ça va mieux ça va beaucoup mieux il
avait rassemblé autour de vous et la
musique et bord la musique votre musique
celle que j'entende vanves vrai nom
héroïne ces tombes s'éloigne ou plutôt
c'est vous quand vous avez envie de lui
et l'a prévenu la vie rêvée
et bien justement c'est pour ça que j'ai
voulu vous voir vous est pas une
il y à un homme qui veut m'épouser
je ne parviens pas à me décider j'ai
jusqu'ici je vis avec un souvenir
souvenir amer mais qui me rattache à
lettres que j'ai si je mens narines et
semble que je travaille quelque chose
que moi même je manque de mots d'amour
alors je ne peux pas j'ai mis dans une
enveloppe la dernière lettre qu'il a
écrit dites moi si j'ai encore une
chance de leur voix oui je vous anciens
et bien l'ombre du nom ne faut pas
s'étendre les plus à vous depuis manier
et je dois même dire quelque chose
non
si si
à vous à vos méninges je peux le dire
cet homme doit vous libérer de lui
complètement
il ne vivra plus et sera frappée d'une
mort subite et comment pouvez vous dire
c'est on va mourir
c'est peut-être pour vous délivrer que
cette mort a été décidé la mort de l'un
fait quelquefois la délivrance de
l'autre la mort si extraordinaire que
cela soit cicatrices les mieux les
plaies de l'amour au coeur que souffrir
toute une existence de la blessure d'un
vivant il ne s'inflige sur un mort
magna ce que vous me dites et à accepter
mon petit accepter que quelque chose
devait lui qui ne vit plus vivre c'est
accepter d'être les plus faibles
c'est dans cette acceptation qui se
trouvent les grands cross je vais tâcher
je vais signer mon petit vous allez vous
marier et vous allez vivre très heureuse
mais très heureuse
merci madame très heureusement petit
j'ai fait un rédacteur qui est la wii
avec lui d'autres lui
on avait besoin de me voir docteur je
crois que c'était pas si nécessaire
madame élire nous allons dire la vérité
tout de suite vient d'abord abbas est
amer
[Musique]
comment allez vous depuis très bien sans
te fatigue pas trop en empêchant les
autres de mourir
parlons de vous d'abord votre jambe et
belle va y va de mieux en mieux je ne
peux pas te dire que je préfère par
ippon carnon aller retour à pied non
je le fais dans le train et tout seul tu
vois mon sujet c'est vrai aussi celle du
coup vous grimpez j'aurais barricades
maintenant j'ai planté le drapeau de
concarneau certains bébés toussaint
pourquoi m'avez-vous parler d'oreilles
temps avant de vous lancez donc vous
êtes y soit ce que tu m'a prévenue toi
que tu vas prendre prises de position
contre le match de ton talent je fais
partie du conseil de l'ordre
je ne pouvais pas ne pas signer
d'ailleurs ce n'est qu'une simple
adresse au ministre c'est une portée
relative mais il y a quelqu'un de
conseil de l'ordre qui a été atteint car
non je ne pense pas et vous trouvez çà c
rie et n'en ont pas besoin d'aller à
bord pour savoir ce qui s'y passe
vous savez ce qui se passait un bravo
hélas ce qui se passe il ya un
guérisseur compte tous les rapports nous
disent qu'il est extraordinaire mais
pour nous c'est pas ce qui compte ce qui
compte c'est qu'il guérit non soyons
sérieux
ce qui compte c'est qu'il n'est pas
mettre sa et comme il soigne nous sommes
obligés de crier casque ou simplement il
ordonne les traitements et qui sont pas
jusqu'au jour où il se trompera si un
musicien joue au 17e rang eh bien nous
ne voulons pas couvrir cette erreur
possible et nous voulons pas non plus
couvrir toutes les erreurs des autres
guérisseurs moins de huit lui en ayant
accepté celui là c'est une position très
très normal non mais les rôles de
médecins voulaient couvrir la science
n'est pas infaillible
l'erreur est humaine alors lui a quant à
elle n'a pas le droit de se tromper
parce qu'elle n'est pas médecin et non
pas parce que cela me tiens prêt de
tromper qui remédie en ces termes c'est
parce que c'est plus cher le temps et ce
médecin se trompe c'est parce que la
science n'est pas infaillible
là elle coupable parce qu'on ne sait
rien et l'autre n'est pas parce que
justement il sait quelque chose
je ne dis pas parce que toi te jure j
entends tu ouvres tu vois que la tête en
l'air
la chirurgie c'est clair si ce qu'on
fait et toi tu fait de miracle mais il
ya aussi des chirurgiens qui se sont
trompés qu'ils ont coupé le bras droit à
la phrase de prince george
c'est toi qui me l'a dit rappelle toi
c'est vrai c'est vrai ce et arié mais ce
ne sont pas des erreurs
ce sont des accidents ya des accidents
tous les métiers donné l'année passée en
or et un dentiste qui s'est tombé malade
il a endormi son client il lui enlever
ses formes de dallas alors là je suis
d'accord avec vous au réveil c'est un
coup dur pour le dentiste et pour le
client janvier et pour tout sur le toit
en angleterre mais comment peux tu
parler l'anglais si tu n'as pas de temps
mais reconnaissez que les dentistes ne
l'ont cependant indispensable
heureusement qu'ils sont là non l'erreur
ou l'accident pour je n'ai rien contre
une progression n'est pas ma tête est le
fait de dire m et pourquoi cette tumeur
chez les médecins ne se trouvait pas sur
le médium qu'est ce que nous sommes nous
sommes en dehors de l'humanité nous
sommes des tigres ne pas faire que ce
que nous sommes voilà ça te fait sourire
c'est tout ce que tu trouves à des
musées écomusée fous toi de moi pendant
que tu es allé au nom non mais je suis
content de revoir de voir votre vitalité
revenus et ça m'amuse aussi devoir
monter sur vos grands chevaux pour
appâter ces drogues de nous voir tous
les deux de chaque côté de la barricade
je trouve un bon dieu mon dieu si les
gens savaient mais le safari
je suis pas venu pour me battre pour
continuer à la pour pouvoir simplement
pour voir ma malades et ma mère tu à
mervans la malade et ça m'a fait plaisir
oui mon petit
tu veux
oui
ta femme les enfants tout va bien ils
sont beaux ma fille vont semble de plus
en plus élevé qu'elle ne vient pas en
voyant un réseau dense chance est blanc
ou une bonne idée danse pendant qu'elle
tournera il n'est pas seul à quatre
pieds très bien s'en aller par michel
paradis moi tout quatre ans car rien du
tout pour pas voulu manger quelque chose
sur le coeur des confrères voiture
pourquoi à cause du fameux projet de loi
déposé à l'assemblée michel et toi aussi
m'a décrit hier si mais si tu suivais
non encore une fois vos mouvements
soient furieux ordre tout au plus
peut-on se demander ce que vous espérez
au juste qui attendent évolué du
remue-ménage vous êtes marrants provoqué
la panne ou même mais chut
tu me demande ce que j'attends ce que
j'espère depuis 40 ans je me suis
interdit le bonheur d'avoir une fille ça
moi nous sommes trois au monde trois
biscottes et moi savoir que mon fils si
aujourd'hui un des plus grands
chirurgiens de paris
c'est parce que pendant 30 ans je me
suis interdit de donner vous ne pas
subir les moqueries quantité enfants
pour qu'à ta carrière son grand allié es
tu me demande ce que j'attends oui
j'entends que voyante comme moi aura le
droit en fils comme toi sans faire de
lien orphelins et sans se cacher d'être
sa mère si grande qu'il soit si fort que
tu sois crois tu que tu est une des plus
jeune agrégé de france
si tu étais le fils de madame karma
mais j'ai vraiment manger je sais tout
ce que vous avez fait pour moi et vous
pensez bien je n'oublie jamais et s'il
n'avait plus qu'à moi vous savez très
bien que je sais c'est moi qui te tout
imposer même la souffrance revivre sa
mère tu me dis vous à l'hôpital du match
mais madame devant le mcs est toujours
un peu comme lorsque je venais de voir
dans son collège en suisse devant dame
que tu ne connaissais pas très bien je
te fais souffrir mon petit je te fais
souffrir comme j'ai souffert moi-même
pour 15 jours ci dessous france perd un
bon résultat et bien le résultat est là
toi toi quelques tuyaux ne fait que pour
toi et pour ça mais cette souffrance n'a
jamais inscrit dans la gorge
tu n'as pas eu envie certains jours de
yule et de dire il tient le doit à tenir
comme les autres et qui voyant n'est pas
forcément un sujet de rigolade et de
dérision
naturellement naturellement et vous
savez aussi que si vous l'avez accepté
lorsque je me suis marié
non je n'ai pas accepté j'ai très bien
fait je ne connais pas ta femme
je ne connais pas tes enfants pour mixer
le site
je le sens de la logique mais ne pas
connaître des enfants c'est dur
tu sais michel là la médecine a mis
presque un siècle pour admettre que le
ca celle que sa monnaie ne va pas sans
leurs lames et il prend l'omnibus et
l'omnibus à cheval encore et quand tu as
un génie confrères comme pasteur qui a
trouvé quelque chose de nouveau
tous les autres médecins leur tombe
dessus je le médium il n'y a pas de gêne
il ya il y a un don plus ou moins
extraordinaire et moi tu me connais
puisque j'aime dans oui ou non
évidemment jong et ben le match de
concarneau en auprès duquel le mien est
peu de chose
c'est un phénomène michel phénomène que
sur la terre pour trouver aux hommes qui
la monte du mystérieux qui ne
connaissent pas alors au lieu d'être
contre lui pourquoi vous ne vous était
pas sur ce phénomène pour essayer de
voir clair dans quelque chose que vous
ne comprenez pas ça vaut peut-être la
peine de remettre tout en question
mais ça sera bon de remettre tout en
question maintenant que le monde
s'élargit que l'homme a le vert' un
vertige de l'espace il sait pas où ilan
et ça vaut peut-être la peine on
reconnaît les choses très très au
sérieux beaucoup de toi et toi quand tu
tiens les gens entrent à vie la mort au
bout des tongs history théâtre en
passant au sérieux toi bas dans mon
métier je ne peux qu'être sérieux toute
la journée
justement c'est pourquoi je me détends
s'il s'agit de refaire le monde parce
que là là là je dise tu sais pas mais
demeure un pâté chirurgien et deux mois
qu'est ce que tu fais comme moi j'ai
c'est que chaque fois que j'ai entendu
maladie ces maladies a existé oui oui
mais pour une femme comme bourg pour un
homme comme celui de concarneau combien
de tireuse de cartes de demi vol dont le
cerveau tourne encore mieux que leur
table à lui connaissait mieux s'il n'y
avait que moi dynamique et le match de
concarneau et bel ensemble
est ce toujours le même demain matin
avec lui il ya un grand diable de la
radio qui passera de voir il faut le
regarder de très près il a un ulcère à
l'estomac bâtonnets tenez voilà un
merveilleux exemple est ce que vous
pouvez imaginer une seconde que tout les
voyantes ou soi-disant médium de paris
nous envoient chaque matin à l'hôpital
un client qui arriverait en dix ans
madame josephine ou madame rosa lee m'a
dit que j'avais ceci ou cela
si vous voyez que si près et si nous
voyons c'est faux ce que vous pensez que
c'est notre avis qui primera celui d'une
voyante a pas du tout niveau bien qu'il
ait un français sur trois qui consultent
les devins des astrologues un sur trois
c'est une statistique officielle les
gens sont tellement l'affût tout ce qui
leur paraît miraculeux que la tireuse de
cartes aux raisons m'ont fait une radio
voilà c'est ça le danger tout en nous
agissions des catastrophes parce qu'on a
préféré la voyante ou chirurgien voilà
est-ce qu'il était arrivé un poids
d'opérer des gens qui ne savaient pas du
tout malade et qui sont venu te voir
parce qu'on voyante leur a dit de le
faire dans ce cas là en général il me
semble prouver ma je t'ai dit qu'uaw par
tous il ya quelques jours j'ai reçu ici
une femme rousse russe
ross il se fait d'un de ses confrères
qui voulait absolument lui enlever son
appendice alors et c'est pas avant-hier
matin qu'il ya les vins calcul dans la
vésicule moi moi comment choix quand tu
te rappelles pas s'il ya un bain calcul
dans la musique rien enfin ma 20e ah oui
oui tu n'as pas très bien
j'étais sûr que toi tu vas lui laisser
son appendice tranquille
alors vous avez vu ce qu'il en était la
preuve
à c
elle a encore des preuves michel tu vois
dans ce cahier
il a tout les opérations que tu as fait
parle dans quinze ans de malades que
j'étais envoyés soit attaqué unique soit
à l'hôpital situe à garder tes notes du
plus contrôlé nous avons toujours le
même diagnostic qui ont opéré grâce à
moi 264 malades
non seulement je te fais ce que tu es
mais je t'avais fait aussi sans que tu
t'en doutes
une petite partie de ta clientèle
tu peux l'emporter ce cahier mais pour
beaucoup comptant les visuels pour
contrôler bien sûr vous vous êtes vous
êtes quelqu'un d'extraordinaire d'export
dix mois quel hommage les cons canon a
donné il faut que je vous raconte à
propos du match concarneau justement il
ya quelques temps je reçoit la visite
d'une salle apparemment en pleine santé
30 ans environ
les longues gentil je diagnostique une
tumeur au sein gauche
mais je demande l'opération sans délai
eh bien vous avez vous ce qu'elle a fait
le lendemain elle a pris le train pour
concarneau à lui la franchise de me
l'avouer très simplement je trouve que
heureusement
heureusement votre marge n'a pas hésité
qu'il a dit comment opération immédiate
dans quelques jours étant donné l'état
de la tumeur et sa localisation je suis
à peu près assuré que cette femme est
maintenant sauvées mais ma voix aussi
que c'est l'hommage avec un diagnostic
pontaroux mien je ne sais pas on y voit
sans doute à cause de tout ce qu'on lit
dans les journaux depuis que vous êtes
occupé de lui alors alors imaginer qu'il
ait pas dit comme moi cette femme était
perdu même au sein gauche
et le mage à des comptoirs et c'est toi
qui avais raison oui mais s'il n'avait
pas été de mon avis c'est lui qui
l'aurait cru
elle me l'a dit voilà alors je voulais
quand même raconté ça
j'ai voulu me raconter ça qui a bien
fait tu as très bien fait
cela dit de toute façon vous avez déjà
gagné quelque chose avec cette
proposition de loi déposée à l'assemblée
c'est tout les guérisseurs les médiums
aux qualités exceptionnelles reconnu
peuvent exercer sous contrôle médical
ce sera pour nous une grande victoire
non
enfin michel
tu n'es pas venu aujourd'hui me voir
pour me parler pour me manifestations
publiques
je veux simplement me raconter
l'histoire de cette femme le rêve
vous avez raison vous êtes le plus fort
vous resterez les plus forts mais pensez
y michel c'est ton dans son sommet la de
l'opération tout de suite lui sans radio
sans microscope
il a vu comme toi la question reste
posée
et bientôt je dois partir maintenant
on vient de vous voir la semaine
prochaine tu sais
mon seul bonheur dans la vie c'est de te
voir
ne vous fatiguez pas trop surtout vous
avez encore à me surveiller pendant
quelques temps n'oubliez pas madame
l'incendié d'un hôtel
le docteur va bien madame
viens te fait mieux
voulez vous prendre une tasse de thé non
merci je ne crois pas vous êtes fatigués
vous poser puisque hot
oui biscotte depuis mon accident
est ce que tu m'as trouve toujours la
même
oh oui madame vous êtes magnifique non
je ne demande pas de me faire plaisir je
te demande me dire si tu me trouves
toujours la même mais bien sûr quelle
idée
pourtant ça fait deux fois c'est sérieux
quoi donc madame savamment petit allez
ça va ça va lorsqu'une jeune fille que
vous aimez bien téléphoné pour vous dire
que tout allait très bien et qu'elle est
fiancée comme vous le lui avait annoncé
attention à ne pas pas dit que n'attend
pas un enfant à noël m'a dit que tout
allait très bien on peut élever de surf
des neiges a prié de vous apporter le
thé de vous servir et elle va venir tout
si un nouveau comme ses amis maintenant
cette vie scott vous pourrez tout dire
est il vrai que balsamique a interrompu
ses consultations oui madame depuis plus
de 18 ans alors ce qu'elle est malade
elle a vu un médecin au n'importe quoi
madame soit mal à 10 jours sans
consultation ça n'est pas normal veut
peut-être prendre à 5 euros
nous avons besoin de ça de temps en
temps le droit aux toits ah oui voit
jamais le jour où j'aurai besoin de le
reposer je me coucherai pour mouiller
non non enlever à autre chose mais quoi
rue d'abord et nous a demandé de venir
vous savez madame a certainement été
très occupé depuis que vous êtes venu la
voir ici pour la dernière fois
puis madame ne le dit pas tout et quand
elle ne parle pas c'est sérieux
je vous laisse de moins c'est sérieux on
sache arrêter sur
pourquoi vois-tu c'est l'hommage de
concarneau bien semblant qu'il inquiète
elle est capable de penser qu'il est
plus fort qu'elle est parfois saga tales
cogné un coup mais karma des paroles
quand même elle n'est pas folle mais les
bizarres bonne trentaine d'années ou de
mois et qu'elle ne croit pas à
l'apparition des esprits maintenant
vraiment une voyante comme elle qui ne
croient pas à l'évocation de l'aude là
ça n'est pas normal mais il y croit elle
se moque de toi pour te faire en rallye
mais elle y croit forcément mais non pas
du tout elle peut l'approuver je ne sais
pas combien une fois elle n'y croit part
je t'assure que tu te trompes nier la
communication avec les morts
c'est impensable en chambre ou un par
exemple j'ai entendu une fois un esprit
reprocher un homme de n'avoir pas
souscrit un engagement testamentaire
envers sa femme allons véritablement ça
c'est quelque chose
comment ça les deux époux s'étaient mis
d'accord pour signer chacun à papier qui
faisaient le surnom hérité du tout la
confiance de l'autre la femme avait
signé le mari non et bien les frais
d'une tente de la femme est venue il a
insulté la traiter de voleur il a
demandé pourquoi elle l'a dit elle a
ajouté que s'il ne se déplaçait pas de
signer elle ne donnait pas cher de sa
peau
on a été chez le notaire
l'histoire ne dit pas s'il est mort le
1er clichy les moeurs trois semaines a
annoncé ce matin qu'il a créée par
ellero que l'esprit s'attendre à ce que
la gauche et garçons nés au zoo sérieux
mais si ma voiture et du côté des
sceptiques qui n'est pas du nôtre
eh bien vous avez raison je suis déjà
plus de votre nom nous présentons nous
présentons envoyé une ouvrages dont moi
je ne plaisante pas je vous ai prié de
venir pour vous mettre au courant d'une
décision est pour vous consultez
j'abandonne la présidence de voyants de
france et je désire être remplacé
comment après tout ce que tu viens de
mettre en mouvement mais veut
démissionner oui mais ça sera suspect
pourquoi questions de santé
et pourquoi démissionner parce que vous
pouvez croire encore à ce que vous
faites moi pas toi avec tes morts et
marquant que les appels à ton téléphone
et d'eau réglera des prix que la dame de
carreau tout ça c'est très bien mais moi
je ne fais plus enfin pourquoi tout à
coup c'est ruby tu ne vas quand même pas
t'arrêter d'exercice heures d'une marine
tu ne donneras plus de consultations
plus jamais mais qu'est ce qui t'arrive
j'ai honte je me suis trompé deux fois
de faire une fois que fois je me suis
trompette 2 2 voies
oui cher nous sommes tous trompés s'en
voit maintenant par contre la non non je
veux dire que nous sommes trompés
quelques fois c'est nous abandonne matin
c'est une catastrophe
tu veux tu qu'je prenne temps plein mais
toi moi oui toi moi président oui oh
mais non mais je suis beaucoup trop
folle pour ça
moi je ne suis pas folle du tout mais je
n'ai rien d'une présidente
je récolte alors bande à van damme n'a
pas d'effets sur la terre tu dois pas
mandat présidente
et puis il ya eu le courage de venir
mais chaque fois que je mets l'encontre
de l'air de dire quel est l'avenir de
remonter du fond de la mer après un
naufrage
cl c'est d'un président d'angus société
à faire un coup
mégalo et à la faune à prendre la parole
avec son dentier
elle ne parle pas elle siffle c'est pas
nous c'est qu'ici puissants qui
contrôlent
vous pouvez tout de même trouver
quelqu'un de normal d'avoir un passé que
tu connais une femme normale parmi nous
heureusement il n'y en a pas si je le
vous êtes obligé de me remplacer
vraiment l'alto attend au mois le
résultat du projet de loi
je n'y avais de m'excuser madame mais ça
va être l'heure dans votre émission
il avait dit aujourd'hui 18 avec l heure
était 6 heures c'est à ses yeux mais il
fallait penser je dis moi c'est dans
l'interview que tu as donné après la
réunion et benoît pas les pensées mes
pensées voilà je cherche radio een
modèle qui partira pas parler de
l'avenir de l'homme monsieur il faut
être sûr de l'anéantissement et on peut
se demander si c'est parce que tu fais
la science alors les crs à venise elle a
fait récemment ce qui nous pose avec les
entraînements ne l'était pas c'est un
fou pouvez les dents dans une interview
de madame karma couple de célèbres
présidente des oies en deux manches on
se rappelle que l'armée avait organisé
ces temps derniers
plusieurs manifestations en faveur du
mage de concarneau montre lequel le
conseil de l'ordre des médecins avaient
pris position de combat blanc parmi les
membres de ce conseil figurer le célèbre
chirurgien le docteur politique en côte
d'ivoire née là où des résidences
alors même si dans cette interview de
madame car marie nous apprenons que le
dr pelletier a été victime cet après
midi à 3h30 sur la nationale 20 d'un
accident d'automobile
sa voiture s'est écrasée contre un art à
10 km dans les jeux dr pelletier a été
cuit sur le
je suis là je suis là j'écoute
parler je suis là
la roma il alors bino pas en parler
alors ils ne répondent pas qu'est ce
qu'ils ont aujourd'hui à l'eau vous ne
m'ôtera pas de l'idée qu'avec leurs
expériences nucléaires et sont arrivés à
perturber d'au-delà se rend bien compte
déjà été aperçue quelque chose au moment
où a commencé la télévision on sentait
que les esprits n'aimais pas ça à
troubler un poil là les interférences
il y avait des moments de silence suivie
par tout à coup des sortes de rap alors
on s'est bien rendu compte le poids du
tout maintenant
non seulement ils ont fait sable ça nous
a envoyé en l'air des obus des missiles
comme ils disent et bien évidemment les
espèces n'ont pas aimé ça non plus oui
mais je sais
oui oui oui mais je guette le plus
gentil mais le plus insupportable des
perroquets tu vois ce n'est pas la peine
de les appeler aujourd'hui ils
répondront pas bien certainement encore
we prod ça tu peux le dire mais qu'est
ce que tu veux le nippon en rien l année
l'autre un bon ami il faut alors la
raison des ruptures dans un temps essayé
mais je ne crois pas oui oui à dos à
l'eau
et puis tu sais ce que tu ne vas pas
rester ici je m'en vais t'emmener à côté
tu es dans la cuisine ne soit rien
je sens très bien dans la cuisine et qui
ne nous dérangera pas j'attends
quelqu'un je ne veux pas que tu déranges
miala mobile uk vient de très bien
arriver
j'allais dire que j'ai raison il est
très gentil et en irlande mais n'ont pas
ou ce n'est pas du tout désagréable tu
es très bien la cuisine je viendrai te
chercher dans un petit moment j'ai pas
tout compris j'attends quelqu'un je ne
veux pas que tu nous dérange a tout
compris oui même très bien tu verras
vraiment très bien là viendra chercher
dans un petit moment
c'est symbolique
à chaque fois c'est elle oui enfin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au chili
pourquoi n'at-il pas voulu que j'aille
chez toi je serais venu tu penses
je sais mais déjà tellement insisté pour
que nous nous voyons ici
oui je voulais savoir chez toi et tu
sais où est bien mal à se trouver
c'était ton fils capable
aucune de nous ne le savait quelle
révélation personnes le savez mon petit
personnes assureront chirurgien c'était
toi qui n'avait pas voulu tu comprends
pourquoi au bien sûr à cause de sa
carrière rosa
je vais te raconter une histoire
extraordinaire qui a commencé ici chez
toi te rappellerai soir je suis arrivé
pour empêcher jeune femme de se tuer
on vous rappelle il a calmé tout de
suite
quelques jours après la venue me voir il
m'a mais l'être dans la main les tours
de l'homme qu'elle aimait pour savoir
s'il reverra sur peut espérer encore
quand j'ai eu cette lettre dans la main
tout de suite
tout de suite j'ai entendu la mort passé
quand j'entends la mort
je ne dis jamais et tu sais comment font
les femmes quand ils ont une amour
malheureux
elles sont capables de faire de leur vie
un cuir l'a passée de l'ombre qui ne
veut plus le voir si cet homme heures
elle sanglote pendant quelques jours à
la fin de la semaine la vie à deux mois
et à la fin du mois
elle se marie alors à m
à elle suivi la vérité je lui avais dit
que c'est on va mourir
il va mourir bientôt quand l'amour c'est
la loi secrète la marche bleue mort de
l'un fait quelquefois la délivrance de
l'autre ils se rebiffent et je lui
réponds qu'elle n'empêchera rien
trois jours après la mort de mon fils je
laisse une lettre que je sais par que
madame carrément vous êtes la voyante la
plus extraordinaire du monde
on m'avait prédit à brève échéance la
mort de long que j'ai tenté mais je dois
dire que vous avez vu clair c'était
mardi dernier à 3h30 dans une accident
d'auto à des kilomètres dans l'air non
non ce n'est pas passive et l'homme pour
qui elle voulait se tuer c'était ton
fils l'homme pour qui je suis venu ici
l'empêcher de se tuer c'était mon fils
cette voix qui m'a dit place de l'étoile
rosa va appeler au secours kim a
précipité ici
cette fois fait de moi un instrument ce
jour là je suis entré dans le destin de
mon fils fait ni toi ni moi nous avons
rien su
et les venues chez moi il m'avait lettre
de michel dans la main est rien j'ai
entendu la mort passé et rien rien à
parler à moi pour m'avertir que londres
je précise et la mort c'était michele
rien ne m'a dit devant cette femme que
l'homme qu'elle aimait
cédilot que gilles et moi plus que tout
le monde j'ai croisés dans mon
appartement
les entrées ballon porte et le sort qui
par le nôtre est rien et le jour quand
nous étions tous les trois chez moi il
m'a toi et moi le jour de la catastrophe
nous étions en train de rire de rire et
de blaguer sur le futur président je
viens de lire comme des vols office
office est déjà mort quoique j'ai prié
ses fiefs et rivières
lien aussi vivre là les fiers-à-bras
pour m'avertir moi l'art ailleurs acquis
vaut croire mais n'a pas loupé ferrovial
moi un peu car ma voix que je pensais
elle n'a pas suffi que je fais mais dont
il a fallu aussi que j'ai fait ma raison
de vivre
tu le sais car là c'est au fond du
gouffre qu'il provient de lever la tête
et de regarder au dessous de soi et de
sécher ses larmes
car vivre cette accepté d'être la plus
faible au est ce que je lui disais pour
que l'accès du c'est son nom
cette jeune femme louis non non bien sûr
ils savent où nous trouver mais pour
nous ils sont des hommes nos salons sont
les antichambres de la vie et de la mort
et nos clients sont des fantômes c'est
petit
qui a aimé mon fils je ne sais même pas
ce nom ni où la trouver
d'ailleurs dans des mois il verra si je
l'avais prédit et c'est la mariée le
toit aussi karma toi aussi tu vivras
visuels pour qui pour quoi
c'est ce qu'on dit toujours après un
grand malin mais nous sommes au nom de
l'esprit ne meurt jamais elle est mort
vive et que nous pouvons parler au mans
par les hommes en rose à parler aux
morts comme ça
lonza je gère ma ville dans les yeux et
les joues pas de moi soit qu'ils
visitent à boké de toi je te demande
pardon je suis venu ablement te poser
question
c'est vrai que le phare qui c'est vrai
que les esprits reviennent bien sûr car
m'a pas vraiment les esprits qui ferma
les frais ils viennent quand tu les
chapelles les esprits répondent et et
j'aurais pose à blois
si justement appelé ma vie je
l'appellerai avec moi car ma nous
l'appellerons toutes les deux poignets
le programme ne suis pas sûr qu'il
viendra t'il bien plein view nous les
quinze jours oui
ce n'est pas moi je viens de là à ce
jour suivant qui n'est pas mort et qu'il
m'a pas menaces dont j'ai géré ma mort
je moi
[Rires]
là
monsieur la pièce que nous avons eu
l'honneur de la jouer devant vous c'est
de monsieur andré roussin
l'effet cause de monsieur av
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avec maurice martel
gisèle casadesus
madeleine d'amiens
[Applaudissements]
pauline carton
genre ok
gallet le roman
[Applaudissements]
jocelyne d'achat
les vianne patrick
mars alicia
dans ce mail
[Rires]
et elle vire en tête
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]